[Music]
in the age of covet 19 hand-washing
videos have spread everywhere so
but to find the first evidence of soap
use and production you have to go back
5,000 years to ancient Babylon
present-day Iraq it was made then by
mixing fats and oils with wood ash and
water the French made the next great
leap a chemist and surgeon named Nicolas
LeBlanc patented a soap making method in
1791 in the mid-1800s Hungarian
physician Ignaz Semmelweis was the first
to really push hand disinfection that
protects our bodies from the outside
world the commercial soap we use today
emerged in the 1900s a process called
batch kettle boiling it was introduced
refined and sold to the nation by a
still growing industrial giant Procter &
Gamble soap is nothing more than the
salt of a fatty acid it works because it
breaks up oil and germs into small drops
which can be easily washed away during
and after World War 2 soap sponsorships
of radio and TV serials in America
became so common people started calling
them soap operas the new wunderbar
so you make your own lie soap back to
you can't Berryhill later there was
granny's lye soap in Beverly Hillbillies
[Music]
and Tyler Durden
paper Street soap company in Fight Club
as your handlers everyone has their
favorite clip and what is this and
cleansing process WL s Rd wet lather
scrub rinse and dry but also made the
right way works
a reminder that old-school methods can
still help solve modern-day problems one
of the great joys in this and what has
been a very difficult time is listening
to my daughter every time when she
washes her hands sing happy birthday
happy birthday every single time does it
even louder now with everything that's
winning it's just I love it my hands are
raw but I love it